it's great to welcome to the program
today edward watts who is
uh both professor and chair in the
history department at the university of
california san diego
he is also author of the book mortal
republic how rome
fell into tyranny as well as the
upcoming book rome's eternal decline
and fall available next year from oxford
university press
it's so great to have you on edward
thank you david i'm really excited to be
here
so increasingly i'm hearing things from
my audience about listen
uh all great empires have fallen in
history
uh sometimes they fall slowly the idea
of the united states
as this a permanent empire
is a historical and you wouldn't even
necessarily know it while it's happening
so maybe as an analogous situation we
can start with
with rome um talk a little bit about
how did rome fall how long did it take
and how noticeable was it at the time
yeah i mean the interesting thing about
rome is the transition from the republic
to the empire is something that lasts
nearly a hundred years uh and it starts
with a series of problems
mainly connected to wealth inequality
that you see emerging
with the development of a financial
system in the second century bc
and the initial phase in this was
one where people were concerned about
the issue but trusted the system to
resolve it
and after about a generation it became
clear the system was not
effectively resolving this issue and you
started getting political conflict
but it took another century before the
system completely collapsed
and i think what you see in that is the
system continually reset itself over
that time
so that there would be a crisis people
would feel like the crisis passed and
they would assume that that was the end
of it
and this long durable and really
successful republican system had
weathered the crisis and would move on
so at the time if you were an
average roman citizen and you recognize
that maybe your life wasn't that good
you saw
inequality much the way that inequality
inequality is noticeable today
you would not necessarily have said this
this
is part of the eventual downfall
i think that that's right i think that
when you're in a successful
political system that's been around for
a very long time the assumption is that
that system
has something natural that that makes it
succeed
and you don't assume that that system is
flawed or that system might be
undergoing changes that could completely
undermine it
and the other thing that's important is
uh in the roman context these crises
would happen maybe once a generation
and so you would live through it and you
would assume that was
that was bad but now things are back to
normal and we can move forward
and it's only with the ability to see
more than a century's sequence of change
that we can say well this is actually a
very long process of degeneration and
decline
but the people living through it didn't
live through that century and
when they did experience these things
they experienced them in real time
and so something that happened 25 years
ago will feel very
distant even though as a historian we
look at this and we say this is part of
a century-long process
and i think in the u.s we can see
something very similar when did this
process of political
degeneration start in the united states
did it start in the 60s did it start in
the 90s
did it start in 2016 um but we
continually think these things reset uh
and
the reality is of course we might be
part of a process that started 60 years
ago
and we just haven't noticed that we're
in the middle of something that will
last a long time
this this analogy this idea is used very
often by technologists and futurists
which
which uh you know they they point out
that
when you are in the middle of rapid
technological change
on a day-to-day basis it really doesn't
feel very fast and because of our
lifespans and the ways in which we
interact with the world
if technology is advancing more quickly
or less quickly it's not often
that noticeable as you're living through
it and it seems that you're pointing out
something similar
i think that that's exactly right um we
experience everything
on a human level in a a day is 24 hours
just like it was in the roman period
and so that means that change evolves it
can evolve very rapidly
or it can take a long time and if it's
taking a long time
we aren't always noticing that process
because our attention shifts to
something else
and so i think the technological analogy
is a very good one
because we live with this on a daily
basis we experience it we interact with
it
and so the changes are things that we
don't necessarily recognize
as part of a long process that lasts
decades or even a century
when we think about the united states
now
as with 330 million people
one of the most populous countries in
the world although certainly not
not the most anymore um is there some
historical
analogy in terms of the idea of
the country separating into smaller
countries and this is something that my
audience asks frequently
typically for cultural reasons in the
sense that you know when you look at the
northeast compared to
most of the states in the mountain time
zone there are not only
they're not only very far when you look
at you know a continent the size of
europe these would be many many
countries away
culturally there are significant
differences uh religiously when it comes
to economics
is there any historical analogy we can
look at for the successful successful
being the key piece
uh sort of sort of a disassembly of a
larger country into component parts or
is that something that historically has
not ever gone well
uh the roman empire actually did this um
so in the later fourth century the roman
empire
devolved into a system of kind of
central administration with shared
responsibilities so emperors were based
in the west and based in the east
and generally speaking that worked
pretty well in the 4th century
but in 395 those territories separated
and
generally speaking that separation was
something that people acknowledged had
happened
but there was this understanding that
the east and the west were one imperial
system laws issued in the east
were binding on the west but eventually
that stopped and as you move into the
6th century there's a roman regime
based in italy that is effectively
separate from the east
and there were conflicts eventually that
developed but
much longer it's a much longer process
and the conflicts developed
after almost a half century of these
sort of
interactions being peaceful and more or
less respectful
and so you you can see this but i think
the process in rome was one where
uh the needs of the individual regions
were
such that the central administration
couldn't effectively address all of the
problems across
this vast territory and the roman empire
was bigger than the united states
at that point and so i think that that
would be the example we might look at
is you if you have different regions
with different needs a central
government needs to be able to
fairly address those challenges and if
it can't
then there really is a need for
something that does more effectively
address regional challenges
than a central administration is capable
of doing there are going to be people
who listen to this conversation
and say that even though in terms of the
number of years
in in terms of sort of uh human history
the last few hundred years of the united
states
uh are are it's a short period of time
that such significant changes have taken
place technologically
uh with regard to sort of the state of
homo sapiens on this planet that
looking at the fall of rome is simply
not analogous to what we have today that
we have
you know uh uh government systems that
are
more developed with all sorts of
different mechanisms from executive
orders the ability to print money
currency treasury you know just you the
the full list of differences
and that what happened then could not
happen now
in the same way what would you say to
people who would assert that
i would say on some level um that's
correct on another level i think we
underestimate what the romans
were able to do okay i'm sorry i would
say that that's correct
in you know in large part because you're
exactly right the technological
sophistication the communication
mechanisms
um the extent of what government does
all of these things
romans couldn't have even imagined um
you know that's an empire that was
governed
based on sending messages as fast as
someone could carry them
and so you had a system that was based
on like it taking two weeks for you to
hear what happens in egypt when you're
based in rome
um and so that's exactly right that
there are really significant differences
but there's also elements of how
polities come together and how people
develop expectations of what it means to
be part of
a political system and in that sense
rome can help us
think about some of the dynamics that we
experience and we see
and so rome i think offers us a lot of
tools
to think with and to imagine what
possibilities might come out of the
political challenges we face
i mean so i agree with you rome is not
it's not the united states
1.0 but rome does offer us ways to think
in a new manner about what could happen
here and to imagine possibilities that
maybe our
most recent and maybe even the american
historical experience doesn't allow for
us
simply because this historical
experience is not long enough to show
some of these possibilities
i i wonder if another difference or i
wonder how relevant another difference
might be
that the power of
militaries and law enforcement today in
many countries
is very different in terms of both its
capacity to repress
certain types of of uh of uprising
um as well as its centralization
combined with the rapid spread of you
know you the
when the george floyd protests started
they
they almost started in tandem in cities
all across the country but they were
really discreetly
and separately organized protests thanks
to technology and communication methods
something that as you point out would
have been very different uh
some time ago what do you think about
that
as you know the power of military and
law enforcement in most western
democracies now
as something that would maybe prevent
circumstances from getting to a certain
point
um i think that the thing this is a
lesson from rome that i think is
important to understand
um in rome you had say in the fourth
century you had about 60 million people
and perhaps 500 000
soldiers and so it was a very heavily
militarized society
and the way that that society worked and
the way military was used to quell
dissent
was uh symbolic shows of force right
you couldn't actually police this entire
empire even with 500 000 troops
and so what you would do is you would
basically um deploy troops
to demonstrate that order and law
were still in place and that anarchy had
not kind of developed and that
there wasn't a kind of separation from
the empire in a particular region
and i think that this is this is still a
feature of
modern western democracies right i mean
law enforcement
needs to um law enforcement does not
have the capacity to be everywhere at
all times
but i think that you're right that one
thing that is different now
is the the spread uh the rapid spread of
protests and reactions to stimuli
um this is something that of course
couldn't happen in the roman empire
because if something happened in say
antioch
in syria no one in italy would know
about it for
two weeks and so you wouldn't have had a
spontaneous protest that happened
everywhere
immediately in response to something
because news wouldn't travel fast enough
and so i think there you do have a very
significant difference that that
presents a real challenge
administratively
for a central government that the romans
never had to deal with
when peop thinking now about 2020 when
people point to what they have observed
in the last four years of this
administration and then
make con draw conclusions from that
about the direction of democracy
or the state of of the united states
is four years even theoretically a long
enough period of time
to actually identify significant changes
in the state of democracy or or is it
simply too
short a period of time uh i think we can
see really significant changes in the
way that we do things and talk about
things in this country in the last four
years
okay the thing that's particularly
alarming to me is uh
the rise of violent rhetoric and then
the fact that we now have
um violence spilling out into the
streets uh and in particular the way
that the rhetoric that's coming from
the white house uh is matched by
armed people going into the streets to
back up this way of thinking
um this is really different than
anything we've seen before in the united
states certainly in the last 50 years
uh and this is something that when this
emerged in rome
that was impossible for the republic to
control
there's a basic idea in any republic i
think but it's
articulated very well by romans that a
republic that is governed by law
can be it can endure forever in theory
uh but a republic that's governed by
violence is not a republic at all
because there's no consensus
between the people ruling uh and the
people being ruled
that this is a lawful way of behaving
and so violence once it
emerges into political discussion and
political debate
is something that completely corrodes
the lawful ability for our society to
make decisions
and so i think that is something that's
happened in the last four years that is
really profoundly dangerous and
really alarming what should we be paying
particular attention to over the la next
for example
six weeks in terms of the election uh
three months in terms of the transition
period
and then the following four-year
presidential term that will come after
that
i think that if there's anything that we
need to be particularly vigilant in
controlling
it's getting violent out of our
political sphere
um people protesting with weapons is not
something that democracies should be
willing to tolerate
it's really really dangerous and the
other thing that that you see in the
roman period is when you
start with that very quickly you start
getting martyrs
you know people who are protesting with
weapons may not actually intend to hurt
anybody it may just be sort of a
symbolic display of the capacity
to be violent if necessary but protests
are heated
and when there's a political discussion
and people are armed sometimes there is
violence that no one intended
but as soon as you have martyrs it's
very very hard to walk back from that
and it's very very hard to remove
violence from a political
environment when you have people who
have died for a cause
and so this is you know especially as
we're looking at the next six weeks and
maybe the next few months
we need to walk back from that everybody
needs to walk back from that
because if you do have the eruption of
political violence
in the context of this election it's
going to be very very hard to control
that
and very very hard to get that out of
the way we make political decisions in
the future
yeah it's a bell that's difficult to
unring once uh what once once you you've
rung it um
we've been speaking with edward watts
who is both professor of
and chair of the history department at
uc san diego
the upcoming book is rome's eternal
decline and fall
due out next year uh really great having
you on and i so appreciate your time
thank you this was great